je vais vous poser une première question
alexis déjà on est en 2022
marine le pen et puisque marine le pen
vient d'annoncer qu'elle sera candidate
d'ailleurs aux élections de 2022
emmanuel macron saute deuxième tour et
présidentielles vous votez pour qui est
ce que vous appeler à voter pour
quelqu'un vous faites comme jean luc
mélenchon en 2017 où il avait appelé à
ne voter ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre
alors deux choses premièrement modejha
bonjour mercian moi c'est dire et
effectivement bon c'est assez clair les
relations qui m'unissent à une des
chroniqueuses mais lorsqu'on a cherché à
faire en le disant j'en avais cracked
c'est que cette affaire soit évacué
qu'il n'y ait pas contrairement à
d'autres parfois qui ont des liens vous
savez en politique avec des journalistes
et qu'il faudra une question comme les
uns mais voilà bah j'ai vécu ça parce
que ça peut sembler un peu curieux alors
la question
premièrement je tiens à corriger que la
position de jean luc mélenchon au soir
du premier tour était de dire qu'il y
aura parmi ces sept millions d'électeurs
insoumis des gens qui iront voter sans
doute emmanuel macron pour battre madame
le pen et ceux qui n'iront pas et le
discours de jean luc mélenchon étaient
entre ces deux positions rester unis et
j'avais précisé les choses j'étais son
porte parole
je crois que deux jours après en disant
pas une voix pour marine le pen pour
karité les choses qu'il est clair que
selon moi quand on vote pour les idées
que nous portons voté par la suite pour
marine le pen est un contresens quel que
soit après le visage que prend
aujourd'hui le discours du rassemblement
national je pense que c'est en vérité un
discours profondément antisociales
dangereux pour le pays fait moi c'est le
sens de ma vie je suis contre l'extrême
droite
elle a pris différentes formes durant le
xxème siècle aujourd'hui elle a un
aspect plus relooké avec marine le pen
mais fondamentalement je n'oublie jamais
que marine le pen a été directrice
stratégique de campagne de son père jean
marie le pen c'est à dire une des
dirigeantes quand il était à l'époque où
il disait que les camps de concentration
sont un détail de l'histoire etc
je veux dire elle est une dirigeante ont
donné l'impression que la reine à voir
et papa mais enfin elle était une des
chèques routière j'ai vécu ça
deuxièmement sans faire de langue de
bois
moi tout mon engagement dans les deux
ans qui viennent c'est d'éviter ce
second tour voilà c'est ça la question
sinon allez non mais attends attends je
te jure je vous jure pellerey a voté
pour et je vous jure cyril hanouna que
aussi c'est ça le sénat bien sûr que
nous donnerons une consigne maintenant
je ne veux pas enfermer passé à son
signal est simple si emmanuel macron je
te dis je
vous dites dans la vie vous tutoie pas
donc il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté là-dessus
mais je je je veux tout faire pour
éviter ce scénario
parce qu'il ya des milliers de gens
aujourd'hui c'est avec sérieux on a des
mises et d'aujourd'hui qui me disent non
mais halloween iran plus voter pour
emmanuel macron en raison du mauvais
sort qui leur fait sur les roten sur la
séance je savais que je veux créer une
alternative pour battre marine le pen
emmanuel macron mayrevieille pas
m'enfermer dans un des deux camps ça
c'est la 5ème république qui nous oblige
à dire tu es fromage ou dessert quand on
plante et maquereau ou lorella moi je
suis mélenchon sera soumis gssa allait
alexis corbière
aujourd'hui on va pas se mentir la de ce
que vous dites mine de rien si on
s'arrête aujourd'hui je pense que jean
luc mélenchon
il aurait de plus grosse difficulté même
que les deux autres affaires des scores
au premier tour je vous dis je vous dise
que l'on pense déjà avec mon élection
que la saison se joue dans les trois
quatre derniers mois donc ça veut rien
dire la fois la position qu'ont les
français aujourd'hui ils n'auront
peut-être pas dans dans un an et
quelques mois
donc voilà d'andernos et huit mois donc
je vous le dis aujourd'hui vous s'il ya
emmanuel macron au marine le pen on a
compris mais drag city emmanuel macron
je pense que vu la politique et magna
malgré la politique que mène emmanuel
macron je vais vous dire on peut faire
deux secondes mais je pense qu'il m'a eu
un coût aujourd'hui s'en fiche d'être
minoritaire il veut un bloc électoral de
20 à 25% ont passionné il plonge à
savoir une tour et 10 face à marine le
pen quoi qu'il arrive je gagne je dirais
manuel acrocime écoute c'est
irresponsable parce que ça a marché une
fois mais vu l'état du pays je connais
beaucoup de gens qui ne referons pas le
vote des manuels macron donc il faut
tout faire pour éviter second tour parce
que tu sais quoi quel que soit ce que je
vais dire ce soir elle elle peut gagner
donc il faut autre chose c'est le pire
candidat aujourd'hui face à marine le
pen vous préférez qui à la place
d'emmanuel macron apparemment évidemment
tout le monde sait ce que je préfère
jean luc mélenchon mais c'est les idées
ce que je veux c'est pas le personnage
alors justement là là c'est décidé je
veux de la république je veux du social
jeu de l'écologie et lui si c'est
l'extrême libéralisme contre l'extrême
droite le pays risque d'aller dans le
mur donc à deux ans aujourd'hui de cette
élection je dis moi sur la cua chevaux
c'est pourquoi je me lève le matin
ce pourquoi j'essaie d'être à la hauteur
de l'honneur qui m'a été fait des
députés c'est faire en sorte que le
second tour soit pas celui-là je pense
que les gens qui manifestent aujourd'hui
ne veulent pas de ce duo là